Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters again, and we're going to be talking about the different
diets and some of the confusion that can come in with a person who has cancer. One of they's
supposed to do. There's a lot of different things out there. You can read different things on the
internet. There could be very conflicting, and it could be very confusing. So we're going to discuss
that in this short little presentation. What am I supposed to do? There's a... Do I just eat
whole foods and try to eat naturally? Do I try to go to what a juice-fasted and, you know, be
eating mainly vegetarian or vegan? Or do I do a ketogenic diet? Or about eating any carbohydrates?
It quite frankly can be extremely confusing. I understand that. And you can find yourself
scratching your head not knowing what to do if you've been diagnosed with cancer because there's
there's information that seems extremely valid. Somebody that has been cured doing a juice-fast-type
diet and somebody who's been cured doing a ketogenic diet. There seems to be a lot of information
that support both camps. So what am I supposed to do? It could be difficult to decide. So I'm trying
to clear some of this up in this presentation. There are really three... You could argue that there's
more, but we're going to talk about the three-made cancer diet camps out there. What are the three
camps that, you know, maybe stake their claim and have a dogmatic approach that this works for everybody?
So I'm going to try to dispel that a little bit because I don't believe everything works for
everybody. Your body is different than my body and what might work for my cancer might be completely
different. What might work for your cancer? So let's talk about the pros and cons of these three
different camps and help to dispel some of the mystical along with it. The first would be the
ketogenic diet camp. That is the Sugar Feeds Cancer Camp. Much has been written about sugar-feeding
cancer and though I would say that any of the camps disagree that excess sugar is bad for you.
We'll talk about that. But a ketogenic diet camp holds to the fact that we want to stop
eating any glucose basically. All food is going to ultimately break down into glucose but there is
a way through a ketogenic, a very strict ketogenic diet that you're using ketones as a fuel source instead
of glucose. So let me explain a little bit. Normally in your mitochondria, you absorb glucose into
the mitochondria, it goes through glycolysis and through the crem cycle in order to make energy.
That's a normal function of your body. When we have excess glucose, we could have all sorts of
problems that could cause us to gain weight that could cause us to have diabetes, all sorts of
different issues. But the ketogenic diet camp when it comes to cancer states that glucose
feeds the growth through the metabolic process to create new cancer cells. So we want to cut off
that diet of cancer feeding our glucose. So we're going to completely eliminate glucose
from our diet and that's how we're going to really win this war. So it has some benefits. There's some
truth behind this and we're going to discuss that. The second diet camp you could say is the vegan
type diet camp. Now a vegan type diet camp would be more towards like the Gertian protocol where you're
juicing a lot. You're staying away from beats. You're not eating any beats whatsoever. Very different.
I mean, the completely opposite of the ketogenic diet camp. Though even in the vegan diet camp, we're
not talking about eating cookies and cakes and that sugar is good for you. They're not saying that,
but it's they're saying that it's not about cancer feeding off of glucose. It's cancer feeding off
of different amino acids and we'll talk about that. There's truth about this. So even though there's
been a lot of people that have done really well with their with their cancer,
anachidogenic type diet, there's been just as many that have done very well, probably many more
than have done very well on a vegan type diet. So we'll discuss that. And then the third camp that
we're going to talk about is really just the mixed camp. This is what I talk more about in my book
because it's just kind of a middle of the ground and everybody could be a benefit from eating more
organic food, trying to eat whole foods, trying to eat the way God created foods to be eating.
That means that you're not eating cookies and cakes and everything either. So we're understanding
that we don't want excess sugar. That causes acidity that causes all sorts of problems. But it's not so
much we're looking at stayed away from all glucose and we're not so much stayed away from all amino acid
proteins either. So that's where the mixed camp would come in. So what am I supposed to do? First
let's talk about the ketogenic diet. This is where it gets confusing because I got cancer, which
what am I supposed to pick? There's no cut to dry answers to this. We'll talk about some genetic
pieces to this that could be extremely helpful in making that choice. But let's first talk about this
ketogenic camp. So how does ketosis work? Traditionally you eat foods that break down into glucose.
It's not just carbohydrates that they break down into glucose understand that even proteins will
break down into glucose eventually. Your pancreas secrete insulin, insulin breaks the glucose into the
cell. It's very simplistic I understand. And then your the glucose is broken down and through glycolysis
and the crev cycle and you make energy. And that's how you live is you need that ATP in order to make
energy. A ketogenic diet eliminates all carbohydrates. And I know there's a lot of different ketogenic
type diets out there. But a true ketogenic diet is getting your your body into a state of what's
called ketosis. Be that your blood glucose levels are are fairly low between 50 and 75
fasting blood glucose levels. And you're using not so much glucose for energy though but ketones for
energy. That is what you from the breakdown of protein you're using that as an energy source.
And the theory is that you're basically starving cancer of its made energy source.
The problem comes in is that glucose isn't always cancer's made energy source. So the baseline
problem comes in is when we start making dogmatic statements that aren't necessarily backed up by
scientific studies. There are many cancers that do feed off of glucose. But you're going to see
there's many cancers that feed off of methionine and different which is an amino acid for proteins.
And we could be doing ourselves a hard beta, a ketogenic diet. If our cancer is feeding off of
methionine and other amino acids because basically that's all working so it is amino acids.
So I go on this ketogenic diet which is very difficult to get your body into ketosis.
And it's so it's a very strict diet and I'm actually doing myself more harm. It's kind of frustrating.
There's a lot of books about ketogenic diets right now. It's kind of a big fad because you could lose
weight on a ketogenic diet. You could gain muscle on a ketogenic diet. So it's kind of big in the
weightlifting arena though as a ketogenic diet. But you have to be careful. There's a lot of
dangers in a ketogenic diet. Glucose is the made energy source for your brain. And when you put your
brain in a ketogenic state, you could go through all sorts of symptoms and issues. And even some
death of neurons, getting into a ketogenic state and it can be harmful. You could have side
effects doing this as well. So I do want to warn you about this. Most of the success with ketogenic
diets and cancer are more with the brain cancers. You've heard of ketogenic diets helping children with
epilepsy. That's because glucose is the made energy source of the brain and we take away that
energy source of the brain. You're not going to have those neurons fired so quickly and not having
seizures. So ketosis, ketones burn much more slowly and it can be beneficial to be in a ketogenic state
in that instance. Now there's other cancers that can feed off of ketones too. So it's not just
brain cancers, but we want to know where you're at from at your genetic standpoint. We're going to
get into that in just a second. It's hard also a difficult thing about a ketogenic diet. It's
difficult to get into a state of ketosis. Many things you'll rate as you just take a urine sample
test and you can measure your ketones with a urine dipstick, but that doesn't mean just because
your spilling ketones in your urine doesn't mean you're in a true ketogenic state. It gets more
difficult than that. But in fact, it is almost impossible to get in a ketogenic state without
initially fasting. You have to fast for three to five days at least. That's just at a strict
water fast, no food to get into a ketogenic state. Now that's difficult for many patients with cancer
that may be looking at dietary solutions when they're now in a stage four and they've already lost
a lot of weight and they might have some kexia going on where some muscle wasting going on and
going on a four to five to six, seven day fast might not be the best recommendation for them.
So that could be difficult. If you truly want to go into a ketogenic diet, you have to measure your
blood ketones and measure those compared to there's a ratio that you go by with your blood glucose
level. So it's a little bit trickier and more difficult to get into a ketogenic state than you think.
It's all doable, so I'm not trying to shy away from this. But there's some things that we want
to know about this. Also, there is a genetic connection with this. Ketogenic diet is going to be a
diet that is consuming an enormous amount of meat and fat. So what does meat have in it? Meat has
proteins. You're eating a lot of proteins and fat. What do proteins have in it? Proteins are made
up of amino acids. This is just a clip from your methionine cycle that you see out here. In the center
of that clip, you see SAM. SAM is your main methyl transferase in your body and SAM is your methyl donor
to many different cells. It helps you reproduce new cells. That's good, but in a state of cancer,
there could be some issues with that. Right before SAM is that circled MAT. So that MAT is actually a
family of genes. There's a number of genes in that family and it converts methionine. See that?
Going backwards on the left hand side of that little picture right there. Methionine. Methionine comes
from, this is the whole methionine cycle. It comes from the folate pathway. It creates methionine. You
also get methionine. When you eat proteins, you have increased methionine. When you eat proteins,
if you have defects in that MAT gene, you can have excess methionine. Also, if you have,
if you're eating just tons of protein, you could have excess methionine. Well, that could be a bad thing
for people that are trying to do a ketogenic diet for their cancer because methionine can feed certain
cancers. So the only reason why a person would do a ketogenic diet for cancer is they're coming
from the belief that their cancer is being fed by glucose. When you do a ketogenic diet,
you're raising your methionine levels. If you also have genetic
snipped defects in your MAT gene family, you're going to have excess methionine. If your cancer
actually feeds off methionine, which many cancers do, there's much research about this. There's
much data about this. Again, not all cancers, but if your cancer is feeding off methionine and you're
going to have a ketogenic diet plus you have MAT snipped defects, that's not good. You are
actually causing the cancer to grow much more quickly. So, ho, golly, jeepers, that's not good.
That throws just even more questions by way, right? Well, you could measure that genetic pathway.
So that's what we do with all our patients and that's what I'd suggest. You do, you can go on 23
and we'll give you more data later and get a snipped defect pathway check and you can see if you
have MAT gene defects. If you have MAT gene defects, I highly suggest you don't go on a ketogenic diet.
You're increasing your methionine levels and you're increasing the risk of your cancer feeding off
of that excess methionine. Follow me. If you're lost a little bit, go back and listen to this again.
We don't want excess methionine and a ketogenic diet itself can increase my methionine levels.
Now, it typically won't, if I don't have any snipped defects, that's defects in that MAT gene.
If I don't have any defects in that MAT gene, well, methionine will cycle through to Sam to saw
and then to homocysteine and down through the CBS pathway, et cetera. And I talk a lot about that in
the gene information on our website. So go to that colors clinic website and click on the genetic tab
and you can see a bunch of videos on it. It'll be really helpful. But if I do have MAT gene defects,
I am going to have excess methionine even if I'm not on a ketogenic diet. I'm going to have
excess methionine. And if I have cancer, that excess methionine can be a not good thing. Follow me.
So there are some ways to know what diet you should be on if you look at your genes. It could
be helpful. All right? So that circle is the methionine. The arrow is the MAT. That's the gene that
we look at, all these little bubbles of this diagram are different genes. And those are measured
through a genetic profile. And 23 and B is the least expensive genetic profile where you get just a
whole spannerate of genes that we can look at a lot of different things, not just this. So that makes
sense. We don't want excess methionine. Ketogenic diets will increase their methionine. But if we don't
have any defects on the MAT gene, that's no problem. But if we do have defects on the MAT gene,
that can be a problem. And a ketogenic diet might not be the right thing for by cancer. Follow me.
Oh boy. So that's not good. So if you do have defects in the MAT gene, I always suggest
do not do a ketogenic diet. That makes sense so far. Okay. Take a deep breath. We're now to the
vegan camp. So we went over the ketogenic diet camp briefly and it'll probably make some more
videos in detail about that. Second is the vegan camp. Should I go on a vegan diet? This is more of
like a gershine approach where we're not going to eat any dairy. We're not going to eat any eggs.
We're not going to eat any meat whatsoever. We're just going to eat vegetables and fruit. And that's
what we're going to function with. Well, the vegan diet really is what I call a low-bethiety diet
because that's really what you're doing. You're trying to decrease that methani levels
in the case of that your cancer is feeding off of that or we're actually, we're feeding the
cancer by causing excess methani levels. Now in this diet camp, you are not worried so much about
the carbohydrates. You're worried more about the methani rich foods that you're consuming. That is
causing a fuel for the cancer. So, though you're still adding cookies and cakes and stuff like that,
but you're really looking at what foods have the most methani in them. Well,
meats and proteins and things like that and dairy things made they have the greatest
amount of methani. So this is really what I said like a vegan type diet. Now we realized that you
do need some protein and this diet does lead towards that. So in general, this is our low-bethiety
diet. I just clip this off of our handout that we use our patients. It consists of diet eating
really 80% fruit and we're not talking about juice. We're talking about whole fruit and 20%
vegetables limiting our greens but mainly vegetables. You need to stay under two milligrams per
kilogram of body weight of methani. That's a one pound equals 0.45 kilograms. So if you weigh 100
pounds, you need to limit your methani to about 45 milligrams a day. If you weigh 200 pounds about
90 milligrams per day of methani, then there's some charts that we give on how many milligrams of
methani and are in these different things. We want to limit fat intake to no more than 5% of our
total calories. So again, we're eating just a ton of fruit and vegetables. That's really
daily what your diet consists of on a low-bethiety diet. If you're at weight, if you're weight that you
want to be at or if you're a little overweight, you could lose a little pounds. We tend to put people
at a 21-day on this diet and then go off seven days and we give some details on how to go off. You
don't go off and eat steak while you're off. But you don't so much worry about all the medium methani
containing foods where you're on your off days. If you're under weight, we don't want you to lose weight
because protein could help keep weight on. So we go 10 days on and then four days off.
So, again, this diet, boy, I'm eating tons of sugar, 80% fruit by gosh, I must be just feeding the
cancer. Well, understand that it is sugar in the form of the way God created it. It's within the
whole fruit. So you're getting a ton of different fiber with that sugar so that you're able to
process it. It's not just breaking down it to just spilling glucose into your body as well.
So, but in a low methani diet, we're not so worried about sugar feeding the cancer. We're
worried about methani feeding the cancer. So that makes sense. So you can see these are very
different, very opposite type diets. Now, the third diet is really the mixed camp. So it's not so much
that methani is causing all my problems and it's not so much this excess glucose is causing my
problems. It's it's trying to eat a mixed camp diet, trying to eat whole foods. This is the one I
really talk about in my book, but it's trying to eat the way God created it because the truth is
diet doesn't always drive cancer. So we can't be so dogmatic. You know, I've talked to oncologists that
say, oh, diet makes no different whatsoever. Well, that's absolutely ridiculous. Okay.
What year are you taking your information from? But we also can go the other way. The diet is
everything. Everything we just need to change our diet. Well, I'm sorry, but there's toxins,
there's chemicals, there's vaccinations that you're exposed to, drugs that you're exposed to,
all sorts of different things that are driven. Your cancer up to this point. Diet is important about
taking that away, but many people's diet is not driven by glucose, nor is it driven by
methionine. So many people, I put after testing them just to this mixed camp diet, try to eat whole
foods, limiting your meat, limiting your carbs, and just having a good balanced diet. So you want to
know where you fit in this. All three of these diets can be difficult depending on where you're
coming from, but there's some hits that go along with what I should be in. I'll get the big
camp is the one I really talk about in my book. And you can read about that. It's a free download off
my website if you haven't downloaded that yet. But I realize this could cause just more confusion.
What am I supposed to do? I always suggest you do some genetic testing. So we do genetic testing
on all of our patients now. The easiest one to run is the 23. It's a saliva test. They'll send you a
kit. You spit in this thing, you send it back post-paid. They'll create a portal on their website,
and they'll send you all the information. And if you're my patient, you're going to contact me,
give me the raw data that we could download and we could go over this because there's genetic
components that hit towards what diet you should be on. Even if you don't have kids or there's genetic
components that hit towards what diet you should be on. And I understand if this is all due to you,
make sure you go on our website, go on the genetic tab and watch some of my videos. It'll help you
understand what we're looking for, what we're going over a genetic profile. So here's another example
of a piece of your genetic profile that suggests that glucose is the thing that you have to stay away
from. If you have a PDH defect, that's the gene to right past that arrow there on the left hand side.
You are going to not be able to make glucose go into the crib cycle real well. It's going to be
shifted straight down that line on that chart right there into lactate and cause an increased
consumption of lactate and glucose by cancer cells. So knowing these different gene profiles,
knowing where you have SNP defects can be essential. Do I have MATG defects? Do I have
LDH PDC, PDH defects? We'll measure all of those and see where we're at and it'll help us,
more information about where you should be as far as diet and what's feeding it.
So even if you aren't my patient, we could still do the genetic profile and I could still do
over the phone a genetic consultation with you. So go to our website and look at first steps
that gives you the prices for all that too. So we just want to help as many people as we can.
So what am I supposed to do? So what are some practical steps? What are my take-homes from this?
I suggest you run the gene profile. The gene profile is only 200 bucks. It is the best 200 bucks
you'll ever spend. It's just a salivary test. You just spin in this little tube. You do it at home,
you said it takes three, four, five weeks to get that back and then contact me and we'll go over
that gene test with you. Before that, make sure you monitor your diet. Be wise. Eat the way God
made it. Stop eating prepared food. Stop eating chemicals and stay away from pesticides and that's
a whole other thing with your genes. If you have PUD defects or genetic defects in your
say to grow P450 pathways, you can't even detoxify well and that could be the major reason why
you got the cancer in the first place. So if you're constantly toxifying yourself with more things,
you're going to be in a world of hurt. So try to try to eat organic, try to make more of your food
and watch my videos. I have a ton of videos on our website not just about genetic things, but
on cancer and Lyme, but everything else more than you can watch in a lifetime probably. I don't know
I keep making these, but I want you to know how to take care of yourself and rather than be
explained all this to each person, I'd rather have you watch these videos so that I can only explain
it once because I'm losing my voice. Alright, so you made it through this video. Fantastic. You get a
treat at the end. Share it with other people and I hope this helps and I'll be praying for you. Thanks.
Bye-bye.